i think we are going to see a
substantial
escalation in the transhumanist
movement and not in the
interesting sci-fi way right
transhumanist back in the day i remember
people talked about they're talking
about cybernetic implants sci-fi movies
integrating with neural link and virtual
reality and things like that which still
could be pretty questionable
but
now it's going to be identity crisis
which we're starting to see a lot of
for for a while there was like other kin
and i don't know if you guys know about
like the tumblr stuff where people
people would say like i was i'm they
would claim to be an owl trapped in a
human body or something like that i know
this girl who's like really really super
into tumblr
um and she was telling me i'm kidding
but um i i remember all of the memes
that used to float around about that
stuff and unfortunately some of it
seared into my mind and the other kin
were a really horrifying i was thinking
we were gonna say i was just gonna say
that i i have had a theory for a while
that the reason why we see declining uh
fertility rates in in countries with
advanced technology is because that we
are moving towards some sort of
evolutionary phase in which the
technology is going to supplant the
reproductive elements yeah i think like
a genderless species that lives in deep
space where we get really long and then
we clone and just took it right to like
the highest level
like you know what i see a hundred years
in the future that's right jack is like
population is declining he's like jack
in space you won't be compressed by
gravity so you're going to be like
floating huge heads have you ever seen
the expanse yeah that's where you got it
from right
the people who live in the asteroid belt
they're like tall and lanky because
there's less gravity genderless too
that's going to be interesting if we i
don't think that i don't think we're
going to become generally senseless i
just yeah no people don't ian's wrong
and and you're technically right but
what's go what it's going to be is no no
no no no there's only one future no no
no no hold on it's because we're
integrating with machines right like did
you guys not listen to what alex jones
had with had been
he was screaming he was like they're
trying to integrate us into the machines
and they want to become immortal they
want to they want to get the robot
implants and things like that neural
link
connecting your brain and your
consciousness into
cybernetics
so it's not going to be 100 years in the
future we're gangly biological no it's
going to be like you guys ever see ghost
in the shell
they put nanites in your brain and
cyberize and then connect you to the
network and then if your body is injured
you get a prosthetic body and then you
you get canceled on twitter they just
turn your brain off right and that's it
you're not just off twitter you're just
you just just
have you guys in the black the black
mirror episode where someone they get
blocked in real life oh my gosh and they
just see the weird like silhouettish
kind of thing moving around
they're like you're blocked i can't hear
you you know what i mean
where i think oh i like that i don't
know i'll say this
jack's like sign me up i am so sick of
people i have blocked 11 000 people on
twitter and i'm not stopping i know a
lot of people are gonna instantly start
screaming alex jones is right you know
whatever so i don't know if he's right
about global elites wanting to turn
themselves into robots
but there have been just general you
know academics and scientists who have
talked about the gradual
integration with technology so for
example i'm wearing a smartwatch we all
have smartphones
we are cyborgs that's the way it's there
i was reading an article and it said
when when will humans fully integrate
cybernetics and they pointed out that
with cell phones we've actually
connected a part of our minds our
consciousness into a massive grid and we
use this connection device to maintain
communications it is it is the
preliminary stage oh my gosh uh google
incentivizes you to write content to do
research to put information out on the
internet so that you can get clicks so
that you get the dopamine it's directly
yes google search is directly connected
to your neurotransmitters in your brain
and when somebody else out there clicks
a button on your thing and you get and
it goes through space and all the way
into your brain it changes your brain
chemistry i as a i'm a twitter
professional i i don't feel bad saying
that but i should
but i do
but i do know i do know that like
twitter is addictive yeah like
i can just feel myself scrolling
scrolling you know i get tens of
thousands of notifications every day so
she's like there's always just something
i read through all of them and i pull it
down boom there's another thousand on it
i was using it i know i just got a wise
phone recently i'm gonna oh wow it's set
up soon yeah what's this so it's
basically it looks like a smartphone you
know call text and it has gps which is
the reason i got it instead of a flip
phone but it's literally just that
calling texting gps i waste so much time
on my phone so you couldn't just delete
twitter no because i know because then
i'll go to the website i'll find a way
around it dude i i once installed like
when i was writing my my book i
installed on on uh on my google chrome
this like uh you know time limiter like
and i assigned different websites to it
and after you used 15 minutes it blocked
it yeah you know and like there's no way
to actually unblock it unless you go
through like a series of like 50
questions but what would i do at first
that worked for like a week
and then and then eventually i would
start downloading new browsers and then
i would start going through the
different browser like i've just found a
way to get around the roblox i had set
up for myself so a phone that doesn't
have the capability or the ability to
download those apps that sounds like it
might be is that the is that that's not
the wise phone no that's not the wise
phone so when i installed it i was
having some trouble because i formally
had an iphone and so people who spoke to
me on imessage even after i turned
imessage off i wasn't getting their
messages on the other phone and i have
clients who communicate with me that way
so i needed to put it back here until i
can figure out how to make it work but i
want to i want to ask all of you guys a
question because i know jack jack's
answer compared to ian's answer is going
to be complete other ends of the
spectrum and then sheamus will make a
joke graphene the question is
dmt humans gradually integrating with
machines and a future where human
consciousness exists in machines
expanding and drifting about space good
or bad
inevitable
bad
bad i'm going to let them answer for but
bad
i'll start with you no sir because first
of all you will and i'm sorry i know
people are going to disagree with me on
this this might spark an entire debate
but you will never have a human being's
conscious mind sitting on a circuit
board what's going to happen is they're
going to attempt to deconstruct a
person's mind and have a computer
simulate that but you cannot literally
move your consciousness out of your
brain and into a computer it's not going
to watch a video those will be computers
emulating human behavior to some extent
but you will be dead you ever watched
star trek
yes you know they have the transport you
know they have the transport kills you
and remakes you yeah would you ever use
one
if it so if it just killed you and your
made you no how would you know yeah
exactly so it my understanding is that
it's actually true in star trek
you
you die and then they recreate you
and so it's just other people see you as
this like approximation this identical
structure but you actually die in the
transport apparition that's disputed
though because
here's
if i watch star trek because there are
episodes and i think there's one episode
in particular where you see someone's
pov when they get transported and they
get transport you see them getting
transported to one place and it fails
and they go back to the other which
means they were conscious through the
whole thing actually that they weren't
dead and recreated except riker got
cloned by a male function in the process
so yeah no you're right it is uh so what
do you want with the show no you're
right it's a plot hole with the show but
yeah this is a famous thought experiment
um
if you were teleported by having your
entire body deconstructed and then
reconstructed somewhere else i would
assume it would kill you and recreate
you but then we come we have a question
we've never seen something like this
occur so maybe when the body gets
recreated there's just nothing animating
it your soul has left your body and you
just have a dead body that's identical
to yours in another place would that not
be really crazy if like we we develop
transportation like matter
transportation technology and every time
a person goes through it they just
reappear and then slump over dead yeah
they're buying their souls like yeah the
soul is gone
so back to my original question good or
bad uh i think bad uh i think it's bad
because i'm trying to envision
a a consciousness of myself
that isn't
immediately drawn towards the ocean that
isn't immediately drawn towards nature
that doesn't immediately receive
positive reinforcement from actual
tactile contact with nature actual
contact with the ocean with the sunshine
and and what that does for me as just as
my soul like what does that do for me
it's it is uh essential to my well-being
i can't imagine those things being
reproduced in a way where you're living
on a circuit board in which the sunshine
actually the transmission of the
sunlight into your body or the the the
alignment that you feel with the earth
when you when you get in sync with the
waves or that you spend time out in
nature deeply simulated bro in the
matrix you know i just i get there's got
to be at some point and we see it now we
still see it so maybe technology gets
better but but there's still a
difference between analog and digital
there's still a difference what do you
think ian
um i think that the the chemicals that
we'll use to build these circuit boards
where our brains will will be emulated
is natural like silicon lithium it's
stuff it's all natural processes from
the earth that we're reformatting we
call it synthetic but it's still natural
stuff that we've synthesized and it's
inevitable and if we don't do it those
that do will enslave and destroy the
rest of us but you're assuming that we
know enough about consciousness to
recreate it and you're assuming that
circuit boards we assemble well that's
true right but
the argument that's made is
consciousness is just information
processing at the level of the brain and
so if we get a computer to process
information in the right way then it's
going to be conscious i don't buy that
at all there's more to consciousness
than that we have a soul and i know a
lot of people like star trek
yes
have you ever seen the make of a man
also i think it's called the makeup man
when data is on trial effectively
determine whether or not he's a sentient
independent lifeform yeah yeah
these are these are tough questions man
well in science fiction we see this a
lot i just i genuinely i don't believe
that we are ever going to create a
circuit board that there is something
that it is like to be
and also even if we could do that which
we can't but even if we could and we're
able to
the idea that you could transfer your
mind from your brain
or in body into that other thing rather
than just having something new being
created or a computer simulating you um
is also impossible i want to remember
this guy detroit become human who i want
to see you play detroit become human you
ever play the game no it's like there's
a bunch of robots that are for like they
look like people and they're used for
menial tasks and they become sentient
and then they demand freedom and there's
like you know analogs to like slavery
and stuff
yeah yeah yeah but i imagine sheamus
would play it like destroy all the
robots they're not exactly they're not
thinking they don't feelings they don't
have feelings well this is the other
question too
because i don't believe that you would
be the first to die in westworld well
and exactly because because once they do
create these machines that are clearly
not conscious but people believe his
conscience just because they seem to be
simulating um
thought
i'm gonna be a bigot right because i'm
gonna say no i'm gonna be saying no
there's no lights on in there and
they're gonna go equal rights for robots
and so then we're going to move
resources that should be going to human
while being in comfort to making us feel
like these circuit boards are happy even
though that's a completely absurd
concept i feel like the high status
thing in the future will be to be as
natural and human as possible
i feel like the plibs
the plebes the plebs are going to be the
ones that get all circuited up and like
turned into work machines and whatever
and like if you can preserve your actual
bio body that to me seems like it would
be the
but they're gonna they're gonna have
they're gonna have fibrous modification
like stronger muscles better bones
so but not the brain it's not the brain
i mean i'm already a cyborg i have i
have seven pins and a plate in my arm
i've got you're not conscious i've got
another humans oh i'm just about ready
to talk about it
i had surgery i had chest surgery i tore
my pec telling the world it came out
uh the pose how was it thank you
it just happens
yeah next is the lever i have a uh uh
someone else's tendon implanted inside
of me and drywall screws and hangers
drilled into my bones and kind of like
like you know it it's it's happening in
that regard but your brain your essence
your soul
you know the last time i was on the show
i'm taking a huge u-turn here last time
i was on this show i said ged a bunch jc
a bunch and a few other things and you
crossed yourself every time i said have
you noticed yes i appreciate that thank
you but i appreciate it but that wasn't
for you that just is yeah i appreciate
it i've had quite an evolution i've had
quite an evolution since the last time
uh we've talked and so i'm trying to
think like this god you know spirit in
me how is it going to be recreated on a
computer board thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com tim
cast irl monday through friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and super
chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time